bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne
l'audition de rémy pflimlin le pdg de
france télévisions il a été entendu hier
par les sénateurs de la commission pour
l'application des lois qui passe au
crible la loi de mars 2009 relative au
nouveau service public de l'audiovisuel
ses principales mesures étaient à la
nomination en vertu de l'article 13 de
la constitution du pdg de france
télévisions par le président de la
république mais aussi la suppression de
la publicité
alors où en est-on de cette réforme est
bien éléments de réponse avec cette
audition bien nous allons commencer à à
leurs deux minutes de retard j'aime
qu'on soit à l'heure donc merci monsieur
films l'un d'avoir répondu présent à
cette audition qui est le point d'orgue
des auditions que l'on fait de façon
intensive avec monsieur legendre qui est
le co rapporteur donc de 2,7 de ce
travail qui doit aboutir avec un rapport
sur la loi audiovisuelle publique
on va pas approfondir et l'ensemble des
sujets plus que c'était un chantier
immense nous les abordera tous les
sujets mais certains plus de façon plus
approfondie nous avons vraiment eu des
éclairages jusqu'à présent très divers
de tous les acteurs concernés par cette
loi
ce qu'ils ont voulu l'ancien ministre
qui était en place à ce moment là même
si elle a du recul qu'elle est engagée
presque de façon partisane se débat
aujourd'hui
surtout quand on parle de la taxe sur
les opérateurs mais en tous les cas avec
sous son regard de l'époque et ce
qu'elle nous a fait un témoignage de
téléspectatrices finalement comment le
voyez l'audiovisuel public aujourd'hui
par rapport aux objectifs qu'elle
qu'elle avait souhaité défendre à
l'époque les partenaires de français les
visions et les les les
des acteurs aussi à part vous on a
auditionné des dirigeants de france
télévisions la cour des comptes etc
enfin ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
les questions essentielles que l'on se
pose c'est d'abord avec l'arrêt de la
publicité comme objectif dans la loi
comme décision se poser deux
conséquences
la première c'était le financement
comment assurer le financement à partir
du coup cette recette il venait plus et
c'était aussi la répercussion sur la
programmation et sur la qualité des
programmes qui étaient aussi voulu par
par cet arrêt la publicité donc on a
regardé de près qu'est ce qui se passe
avec le financement qu'est ce que l'on
peut prévoir aussi et puis on a regardé
de près les objectifs quand on disait
tranche de programmes notamment sur
france 2 qui commencé autour de 20h35
qu'elle un pas que ça avec l impact en
prime time ça avait sur les oeuvres
diffusées le fait de ne plus être sous
la contrainte d'un audimat à cause de la
contrainte commerciale puisque l'on peut
dire que le du mat et tout le temps
recherché quand même on veut être vu
et puis la conséquence de tout cela qui
était enfin la conséquence non le
l'outil pour arriver à ses objectifs qui
étaient l'entreprise unique la fusion
avec des discussions que l'on avait eu
sur la centralisation le guichet unique
avec la première équipe vous quand vous
êtes arrivé qu'il y avait voulu redonner
place autonome aux chaînes haut et donc
cet effet de décentralisation en prob
après ce premier effet de centralisation
tout ce que ça impliquait pour
l'organisation français des visions les
conventions la rationalisation et le
média global qui était encore un des
objectifs affichés qui on a pu constater
enfin sans vous y reviendrez vous nous
direz qu'il y avait du retard on peut
dire globalement au moment où c'est toi
et est arrivé on peut pas dire que la
france est le logo visuel public
français était à la pointe et les
résultats tout à fait satisfaisants que
l'on peut constater aujourd'hui dans ce
domaine avec l'interrogation mais pour
aller plus loin et aller au bout ce
qu'on peut rester avec ce niveau
d'investissement qui est quand même pas
terrible on va dire puisque il ya un
problème de financement
donc le problème du financement vous
connaissez j'aimerais bien avoir votre
point de vue parce que là on a gratté on
a même auditionné la commission
européenne pour en savoir plus il y
avait deux moyens pour l'état même si
c'était pas affecté qui était de
compenser la perte de la publicité
c'était la taxe sur la publicité qui
s'évade révèle chaînes traditionnelles
sous évalué à 70 millions ce que ça
devait rapporter ça en rapporte au mieux
20 millions et ça s'est pas concentré au
plus sur ce qu'on croyait puisque la tnt
avec le pluralisme a absorbé quand même
les choses que la crise financière
passant par là de toute façon le marché
publicitaire se rétrécissant les effets
escomptés n'ont pas été au rendez vous
il ya eu il y avait la taxe il ya la
taxe qui est perçu sur les fournisseurs
d'accès mais on sait que ces attaques et
à la commission européenne on sait qu'il
ya une condamnation la commission
européenne on sait qu'il ya un jugement
qui va être rendu pour finir avec
différents et dire ce qu'il faut faire
on me dit que la commission européenne
que nous avons auditionné nous dit que
probablement entre janvier et juin 2013
est plutôt à la fin du sommet ce que
vers le début du semestre
on saura où va je vous dirai pas ce que
les uns et les autres moody sur la
probabilité d'être sanctionné mais elle
est forte ou tous les cas on ne peut pas
faire comme si cela n'arriverait pas
parce que nous sommes obligés nous aussi
législateur mais les pouvoirs publics
devront aussi prévoir pour pas que ça
nous tombe dessus n'importe comment
il y aura le problème si on est
condamnés du remboursement mais ça
l'état devra voir comme un effet qui
n'est pas automatique
saleh a pris puisqu'ils ont une
condamnation et ensuite ce sont les
opérateurs qui peuvent saisir ici pour
demander pas s'arranger
en tous les cas c'est pas quand on la
commission européenne condamne à leurs
indics c'est illégal
voilà et mais ne dit pas vous rendez
l'argent ça c'est ce qui les a nommés
devant nous c'est que on ne l'aura plus
cette recette l'état comment l'état
réagira dans le moment où sa dette et
est énorme dont il ya quand même des
ombres qui plane sur la question de la
publicité je vous monsieur le gendre
précisera encore plus probablement cette
question parce que ça lui tenait à coeur
mais on avait eu l'occasion de vous
parler personnellement mais bon il ya
une interrogation sur le vers 20h35 est
devenu vers 20h45 et le dimanche c'est
encore plus proche de 21h et donc
certains s'émeuvent
de cette dérive il ya des raisons
probablement tous les cas que vous que
vous défendez certains ne sont pas
convaincus que ce sont de bonnes raisons
tous les cas que c'est pas dans l'esprit
complètement ce que voulait le
législateur donc c'est là aussi
j'aimerais qu'on vous en tant que vous
expliquer quel est votre point de vue
est pourquoi les choses sont comme ça
voilà il ya aussi on s'émeut que la
création bon en gros quand on parlait de
qualité vous pouvait se permettre le
service public en prime time
parce qu' il pouvait prendre des risques
que le privé ne prenait moins vu vu eux
a pu appeler la dictature commercial de
l'audimat mais bon moi je n'emploie pas
des termes aussi radicaux dans tous les
cas cette pression le pari maupassant
oeuvres classiques qui avait en plus
marcher puisque ledit matete en plus
cela a été un peu abandonné pour quelque
chose qui serait plus en des oeuvres
plus en phase on va dire avec avec la
société telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
ses enjeux ses moeurs et ses conflits et
l'impression que ça existe déjà un peu
sur france 3 et que ce tournant laisse
cette spécificité sur les oeuvres
classiques qu'elle est et ce pari et qui
était apprécié par un certain public bon
ce sont des exemples choses qui nous
sont venus comme interrogation en tous
les cas la publicité aussi n'a pas été
arrêtée comme prévu dans la loi
définitivement à vous et après boutin
et c'est poser aussi la question que
pour les téléspectateurs souvent ce
qu'on appelle le parrainage et cetera
est perçue complètement comme de la
publicité ne vois pas tellement la
différence et ça aussi en pression que
c'est peut-être un détournement de ce
qu'a voulu le législateur je ne fais pas
qu évoqué ce que je pense ou ce que vous
pose comme question mais toutes les
questions qui ont été mis sur la table
à travers nos auditions et je conclus
avec cette question sur sur notre
présent unique et cette gigantesque
entreprise pour de de fusion on sait ce
que ça veut dire tous nos interlocuteurs
emploie le mot paquebot parlons de
france télévisions serait bien si
c'était une vedette rapide mais certains
ont parlé d' enlisement à cause de
réforme interne successifs qu'il faut
que depuis à peu près cinq ans ils ont
l'impression coulé on sait toujours pas
quel est le bon interlocuteur il va
changer la bonne organisation puisque je
vous ai dit centralisation
décentralisation forcément nouvelle
équipe etc
c'est quelque chose qui a été évoqué qui
qui donne l'impression que bon et il
faut toujours bien des choses positives
pour finir j'ai dit un peu tout à
l'heure mais l'idée que sur le média
global il y avait du retard à l'allumage
mais que ça avance vite et ça ça a du
succès ça marche bien
donc mais je vous dis aussi quand
j'étais en nous étions à la commission
car peut on avait considéré qu'il
fallait 250 millions d'investissements
pour pour être être vraiment dynamique
et avec toutes les difficultés
financières ou je vous ai parlé on peut
s'interroger sur le fait que si on ne
poursuit pas avec des vrais moyens pas
convié drew samassa a bien commencé
donc on met l'argent ailleurs s'il n'y a
pas là quelque chose comme c'est une
course d'une compétition pas seulement
nationale mais internationale
on peut très vite dans ce domaine
notamment du numérique est un peu en
retard donc question sur comment vous
anticipez tout cela voilà c'est très
vaste
on a une heure d'autant que monsieur
qu'ensuite c'est une audition assez
importante ici qui n'est pas un lien
direct avec ce sujet on verra tout à
l'heure monsieur trévidic pour un autre
sujet et les sert à ne pas trop le faire
à temps donc on a une bonne heure ce qui
est largement temps merci monsieur china
et à toute votre équipe là que je vois
devant moi on a l'habitude de voir sous
l'eau merci d'être d'être là et au fait
comme d'habitude si vous considérez que
des points doit être développée par vos
collaborateurs
c'est avec plaisir que les entendra
merci monsieur le président
dream ces gens pour rapporteur
j'aimerais peut-être d'ailleurs madame
blanc d'art d'ailleurs madame blandin
aussi bien entendu à chaque fois que
dans cette commission nous auditionnons
demandons à la présidente de la
commission concernée par le sujet je me
suis dit lui aussi qu' on s'appuie
beaucoup pour nos auditions sur le
travail d'évaluation car déjà fait
madame morin desailly quels rapports que
nous les connaître qui nous aide aussi
puisque c'était presque rapport d'étape
pour doute
voilà oui monsieur le président de la
commission monsieur le président de
france télévisions nous livrons avec
vous aujourd'hui un exercice assez
délicat il s'agit de ne pas reprendre un
débat sur la loi sur l'audiovisuel qui a
pu avoir lieu auparavant et pour lequel
nous avons les uns les autres exprimé
des positions certains ont voté le texte
d'autres ne l'ont pas voté il s'agit
évidemment pas ici de chercher à savoir
si ce qu'ils n'ont pas voté avait raison
aussi ceux qui ont voté avez raison il
s'agit me semble-t-il dans l'esprit
républicain de s'assurer que la loi
telle qu'elle a été votée par le
parlement est correctement appliquée il
s'agit aussi de voir si nous n'avions
pas aperçu un certain nombre de
difficultés qui éventuellement
pourraient expliquer une remise en
question de l'application de la loi
votée par le parlement
je dois dire que en ce qui me concerne
j'ai été un soutien assez enthousiaste
de cette loi parce que j'y voyais un
aspect culturel important donné une
nature et une identité tout à fait
différente à france télévisions par
rapport aux télévisions commerciales en
faisant en sorte que son mode de
financement ne soit pas celui que ne se
soit totalement différent de celui des
télévisions commerciales
voilà pourquoi il est légitime de
regarder comment évoluent les recettes
de france télévisions mais permettrait
aussi de dire que pour le public qui
avait été retenu me semble-t-il pour
l'essentiel voté par le parlement et
compris par le public
c'était l'arrêt de la publicité au moins
pendant une certaine tranche et il est
vrai j'insiste là dessus je souligne
l'évoquait tout à l'heure aussi qu'il y
a maintenant une certaine ambiguïté dans
l'esprit du public qui voit des tranches
de parrainage apparaître après la le
journal télévisé du soir qui veulent le
sentiment qu'on avait annoncé la fin de
la publicité et que la publicité sous
d'autres moyens ou sud ou sous une autre
appellation persiste alors que l'on
pensait ainsi que le strict respect ou
un respect presque script du 20h35
permettrait d'avoir une soirée télévisée
avec deux films éventuellement sens où
deux grandes émissions sens
obliger le téléspectateur à se coucher
trop tard alors pourriez-vous être assez
précis monsieur le président dans
l'analyse que vous pouvez nous
développer sur les raisons de cette
situation l'évolution que vous souhaitez
donner à votre chaîne pensez vous que
vous respecter l'esprit de la loi en
ayant une situation dans laquelle
finalement la grande émission du soir de
france télévisions peut commencer à peu
près à la même heure que celle de son
concurrent de la première chaîne voilà
nous aimerions avoir là dessus et sur
votre compréhension des choses une trés
des précisions j'aurai d'autres
questions à penser à poser ensuite mais
je crois pour l'instant je vois déjà me
limiter à ce premier point qui pour moi
est d'abord une forme de signature
culturel de la nature des programmes de
france télévisions moi je suis ici en
auditeurs et je suis tellement avide de
vos réponses que je ne vais pas prendre
deux minutes sur votre temps de parole
madame la présidente monsieur le
président monsieur président legendre
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je suis
heureux de pouvoir échanger avec vous
aujourd'hui sur les modalités
d'application de la loi du 5 mars 2005
cette loi monsieur le président vous
l'avait bien dit qui a modifié en
profondeur l'organisation le modèle
économique et la programmation des
soirées des chaînes de france
télévisions je voudrais d'abord rappeler
que le service public doit être dans un
rapport de confiance avec les citoyens
car il est porteur de valeurs
républicaines et d'une grande
responsabilité dans la façon dont
quotidiennement nous informons les
français nous les aidons à comprendre le
monde et nous nous attachons à les
divertir mais aussi dans la manière dont
nous reflétons la société dans cette
diversité et dont nous efforçons de
parler à chacun c'est à dire à
l'ensemble des publics alors d'un
renforcement de l'offre privée dans la
tnt une tnt dont beaucoup s'accorde à
dire qu'elle n'a pas enrichi qualité
vivement le paysage audiovisuel
l'identité du service public s'affirme
plus que jamais dans l'exigence de
différence de nos offres avec celles des
chaînes commerciales
oui france télévisions est un groupe
dont la qualité des programmes
constituent cette alternative et
contribue fortement à informer enrichir
et divertir le téléspectateur la mission
centrale de france télévisions la
première du fameux triptyque des
fondateurs de l'audiovisuel public qui
est d'informer nos concitoyens dans le
pluralisme ne s'était pas aussi bien
porté depuis longtemps je rappelle que
les rédactions de france télévisions
sont depuis mon arrivée placé sous une
direction unique et c'est la référence
notamment à l'entreprise unique monsieur
le président sur france 2 le 20 heures
est revenue à des niveaux d'audience
inédit depuis 15 ans nous avons
reconstruit avec des paroles et des
actes la grande émission politique qui
manquait à notre pays
france 2 est actuellement le lieu du
débat démocratique audiovisuel france 3
avec ses 24 éditions régionales et 49
édition l'école locale simultanée rempli
son rôle central
quelles informations régionales de
proximité de nos concitoyens le 19/20
sur france 3 hormis en ile de france et
dans les régions qui l'entourent fait de
france 3 la première chaîne sur cette
tranche très loin devant toutes les
autres chaînes avec des parts d'audience
qui vont de 20 à 30 % dans certaines
régions
l'information mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à retrouver sur france
télévisions ce rôle central et constitue
une alternative crédible et forte
indépendante et pluraliste aux offres
privées et la lecture d audience
nationale de france 3 doit être
interprété au regard du chemin
résolument régional que cette chaîne
emprunte depuis mon arrivée les comparer
à celles des chaînes commerciales qui ne
remplissent aucune de nos missions de
service public n'a pas de sens en
matière d'éducation des téléspectateurs
je n'insisterai pas sur la popularité
les audiences croissante de france 5 qui
montre bien à quel point nos concitoyens
souhaitent une télévision qui permet de
partager la connaissance le savoir et la
culture
et nous pouvons être tout aussi fier de
la réaction du public et de l'accueil
critique reçu par l'exceptionnelle
documentaire guerre d'algérie la
déchirure en première partie de soirée
sur france 2 il ya quelques semaines
france télévisions propose en permanence
une offre documentaire exceptionnel
s'adressant à tous à des niveaux de
qualité et d'engagement qui montre là
encore la singularité du service public
dans le paysage français
france 4 vient encore d'en administrer
la preuve face à m6 ce n'est pas moi qui
le dit mais isabelle morini-bosc dans la
rédactrice en chef de tv magazine le
plus lu des magazines des programmes
télé en france dans le domaine de la
création que vous avez évoquées et dont
vous savez qu'elle est primordial dans
mon action
la nouvelle saison de la fiction un
village français sur france 3 démarre
avec un succès critique et public
elle traite des drames de l'occupation
allemande et constitue l'exemple de ce
qu'est depuis toujours la raison d'être
de france télévisions raconter la grande
histoire de notre pays expliquait le
monde à travers la vie et l'histoire des
hommes
sur france 2 la série fais pas ci fais
pas ça est un autre exemple de succès
critique et public que nous seuls
pouvions accompagné patiemment dans la
rencontre des téléspectateurs comme la
série les hommes de l'ombre
cette création est emblématique de la
nouvelle ligne éditoriale résolument
contemporaine que j'ai souhaité impulser
pour les fictions de france 2 depuis 2
vendredi et encore vendredi prochain la
série en six épisodes
antigone 34 montrent l'engagement de
france 2 dans de nouvelles écritures
françaises et européennes cap que
l'arrêt de la publicité après 20h nous
permet de prendre en privilégiant très
clairement certains soirs l'innovation
sur l'audience
et c'est un point extrêmement important
qui répondent à vos préoccupations je
pense cela montre aussi le chemin à
parcourir pour conquérir de plus jeune
public sur ces nouvelles formes de
création et l'opiniâtreté dont les
équipes de programmes doivent faire face
preuve face aux attaques des
commentateurs au moindre revers
d'audience dans le sport avec l'arrivée
des qataris dans ce domaine france
télévisions devient le seul véritable
garant d'une offre de sport gratuite
pour les frais
c'est dans le contexte budgétaire que
vous connaissez nous avons sécurisé sans
surenchère tous nos droits sportifs est
essentielle pour les quatre prochaines
années
après le tournoi des six nations la
communauté nationale va se rassembler
sur france télévisions devant roland
garros le tour de france et les jeux
olympiques
là encore mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs france télévisions offre aux
français une alternative unique
démocratique est pleinement de service
public dans toute l'europe
à l'heure des audiences fragmenté de la
tnt les groupes audiovisuels cherche à
reconquérir des téléspectateurs plus
jeunes grâce à l'une de leurs chaînes
bbc 3 au royaume uni zdf néo en
allemagne rail quattro en italie 7 à
france 4 de jouer en france cette
partition est essentielle elle n'est pas
la caricature que certains cherchent à
en faire elle est en train de réussir sa
rencontre avec les téléspectateurs
quel rap car elle apporte une richesse
qualitative que lé baromètre confirme
bien sûr elle pourra encore progresser
dans ses missions jouer mieux son rôle
d'expérimentation faire émerger des
nouveaux talents notamment en matière de
fiction mais elle est déjà la seule
chaîne nouvelles de la tnt qui
soutiennent à ce point la création et la
production documentaire la seule qui
diffuse des courts métrages
la seule qui diffusent des films d'art
et d'essai la seule qui dépassent
nettement ses obligations programmation
de films français qu'elle va encore
renforcer grâce à un accord que j'ai
signé avec la profession du cinéma il y
a une semaine
enfin son antenne en est la preuve
permanente elle est pleinement ce
partenaire du spectacle vivant qui a le
coeur de son cahier des charges
fin 2010 la france a connu une évolution
exceptionnelle avec l'arrivée de la tnt
dans tous les outre-mer de la république
dans un dispositif opéré par france
télévisions et m'a jeté ma rouges
majoritairement composée de ses chaînes
je tiens à saluer le travail de nos
équipes qui dans un délai
particulièrement serré on réaliser ce
saut démocratique pour nos concitoyens
nous avons désormais neuf chaînes
dénommé premières qui ont partout des
parts d'audience considérable
elle ne rediffuse plus comme avant le
meilleur des programmes des chaînes
nationales et font mieux que résister
face à une concurrence élargie
france ô pour sa part devenu pleinement
chaîne nationale a engagé une nouvelle
étape et construit son repositionnement
autour de l'ouverture à toutes les
cultures du monde au premier trimestre
2012 france télévisions est fort de 30 %
de l'audience de nos concitoyens d'après
l'union européenne de radio-télévision
la moyenne des audiences des groupes
audiovisuels publics en europe s'établit
juste en dessous de 29%
prenons l'évolution de france 2 qui
demeure la grande chaîne généraliste
alternative aux chaînes privées
historiques
elle résiste mieux que tf1 dans la tnt
l'écart entre ces deux chaînes et 2 9
points d'audience aujourd'hui il était
de 17 points en 81 12 années typique de
bonne santé pour les deux chaînes à
l'époque tf1 avec 41% de l'audience
nationale et france 2 en avait 24 en
2011 tf contre 24 % de l'audience
nationale et france 2 rassemble 15 % des
audiences sur la même période
france 3 est passée de 13,6 à 9,7 de
part d'audience je le crois mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs dans un secteur
qui a tant changé en france et dans le
monde france télévisions résiste bien et
continue d'assumer l'émission
télévisuelle qui doivent être les
siennes auprès de nos concitoyens
ces missions notre raison d'être ne sont
pas différente du passé
la révolution numérique renforce même
notre utilité en tant que porteur des
valeurs de la communauté nationale dans
le monde des contenus et de numérique
pour reprendre la formule du cinéaste
italien rossellini plus que jamais
france télévisions doit être une grande
encyclopédie populaire des temps
modernes une encyclopédie vivante sans
cesse en mouvement qui place
l'accompagnement de la création en son
centre
ce qui a complètement changé c'est le
contexte dans lequel il nous faut
exercer nos missions avec six nouvelles
chaînes de la tnt va encore renforcer
l'offre privée est limité
proportionnellement le service public
l'inflation sur les droits audiovisuels
elle se du sport en premier lieu va
continuer sa course et limiter encore
notre capacité d'achats de programmes
la télévision connectée qui met en
france la puissance de google et d'apple
au centre du jeu va nous imposer à court
terme de revoir totalement nos modèles
l'essor des nouveaux usages numériques
délinéarisée la télévision de rattrapage
et la vidéo à la demande
ces nouvelles pratiques audiovisuelles
des français comme la force de
prescription des chaînes nous devons
renforcer notre rôle d'éditeur de
programmes en complément de celui de
diffuseur les producteurs ne le
comprennent pas tous notamment dans les
domaines du documentaire et de la
fiction ce contexte commun à tous les
audio visuel public en europe
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs est
celui d'une concurrence inédite dans
l'histoire de l'audiovisuel public
je veux ici vous faire passer un seul
message aider le groupe france
télévisions et des le patrimoine
audiovisuel commun des français à
relever les défis qui sont les siens
prioritairement france télévisions a
besoin de pouvoir se projeter dans un
cadre financier stabiliser afin
d'affronter les défis qui l'attendent
c'est l'objectif du com contrat
d'objectifs et moyens 2011-2015 que
j'avais souhaité négocier à mon arrivée
objectif contredit déjà deux reprises
par des arbitrages correctives diminuant
les ressources publiques affectées à
france télévisions c'est pour nous une
source d'inquiétude
d'autant que nos perspectives
publicitaires déjà morose du fait du
contexte économique général seront
affectées par l'arrivée des nouvelles
chaînes privées de la tnt
la question qui vous appartient du
maintien ou de la suppression de la
publicité en journée au 1er janvier 2016
doit être posée à l'aune de la volonté
de l'état de nous assigner des objectifs
plus nombreux comme par exemple le
financement de la création ou l'essor de
l'outre-mer audiovisuelle nous
partageons ces défis avec tous les
audiovisuel public européen
il conditionne les trois axes
fondamentaux de la stratégie que je
conduis à france télévisions que je
voudrais rappeler le mans brièvement
vous rappeler pour conclure
premier axe je ne développerai pas car
nous manquons tendent mais cet essentiel
vous l'avez dit monsieur le président
c'est notre offensive dans le numérique
nous y allons de très importantes
ressources plus de 100 millions d'euros
sur les trois prochaines années
rappelons le en première le premier acte
c'est le lancement de notre plateforme
d'information qui sera suivie bientôt
d'une plateforme sur le sport vous
l'avez compris j'ai considéré que
l'information et le sport comme les deux
priorités à court terme de mon mandat
le deuxième axe c'est la poursuite de la
construction de l'entreprise unique et
la réforme des structures de france
télévisions que vous avez aussi évoqué
monsieur le président la nouvelle équipe
que je dirige depuis 18 mois a pris en
charge une entreprise totalement
désorientés et désorganisés par la mise
en place à marche forcée de l'entreprise
unique en un an à vous et à tous ceux
qui ont l'impression que le
fonctionnement de france télévisions
n'est pas clair pas fluide je veux le
dire aujourd'hui vouloir faire cela en
un an et même en 2 n'était pas réaliste
l'entreprise unique et est et reste une
nécessité une évidence même dans le
paysage qui est le nôtre mais fusionner
huit sociétés cinq chaînes et même 14
avec celle des outre-mer rassemblant
plus de 10000 collaborateurs des chaînes
que l'histoire a conduit à se construire
en opposition les nuls aux autres cela
demande du temps du temps pour négocier
les statuts collectif pour exposer la
nouvelle organisation instance et au
personnel pour rapprocher fluidifier les
procédures et les outils de travail
notamment informatiques comme pour
regrouper physiquement les
collaborateurs des nouveaux services
communs dans ce paysage en constante
évolution
nos collaborateurs donc ne pourrons
construire un groupe uni et adaptée aux
mutations du secteur audiovisuel et du
numérique
khaled de trajectoire pluriannuelle
tenant le plus grand compte de ce corps
social
surtout si ces effectifs doivent
diminuer car la télévision n'est faite
que par le désir le travail d'hommes et
de femmes
j'ai établi une feuille de route interne
en application de nos grands chantiers
stratégiques qui conduira france
télévisions est une étape importante
un d'achèvement de l'entreprise unique
fin 2013
en adoptant une étole une méthode
nouvelle respectueuse des personnes ce
qui pour moi vous le savez prime sur
toute autre valeur des étapes sociales
importantes ont enfin été franchie la
signature d'une nouvelle convention pour
les journalistes et la négociation en
cours sur le temps de travail au coeur
de cet axe stratégique fondamentale se
place la réforme de france 3 j'ai engagé
cette réforme pour moderniser cette
chaîne que je connais si bien à mon
arrivée nous avons en premier lieu
mobiliser le potentiel sous-employés des
équipes et augmenter sensiblement leur
production tout en baissant le coût de
production
je souhaite désormais passer à une autre
étape conforme à ce que j'avais indiqué
lors de mes auditions 2010 une étape qui
s'inspire toutes choses égales par
ailleurs de la rd allemande de
constituer des pôles régionaux
d'excellence audiovisuels numériques et
culturel du nord mission qui associe les
acteurs locaux publics associatifs ou
privés tant il est aujourd'hui patent
que l'offre privée locale qui fondaient
de nombreux espoirs ya dix ans n'a pas
partout trouver sa place ou son modèle
économique
je souhaite réformer profondément les
structures de france télévisions ces
fonctionnements internes autour
d'objectifs de cohésion et d'efficacité
afin d'affecter prioritairement nos
marges de manoeuvre au contenu et
notamment à la création dans un univers
de ressources publiques que nous savons
nécessairement contre à mon troisième
axe stratégique à l'heure du
morcellement des audiences et la
construction de véritables synergies
dans notre bouquet de chaînes ce qui
implique d'adapter pour les réaffirmer
les identités et les lignes éditoriales
de chacune en renforçant le socle de
valeurs qui nous est commun
les chaînes privées qui domine la tnt en
complètement transformé leur
programmation en soirée en profondeur
elles l'ont modifié de façon dont les
français regardent la télévision
ayant perdu une partie de leur puissance
aux heures de grande écoute elle
travaille désormais à capter les
téléspectateurs le plus longtemps
possible les notion même de première
deuxième et troisième partie de soirée
disparaissent
le téléspectateur fait son choix vers
21h et reste captive de la même chaîne
jusqu'au coucher les grandes émissions
de divertissement du privé dure
désormais plus de trois heures les
épisodes de séries sont programmés bord
à bord et les coupures publicitaires
n'intervienne qu'une fois le
téléspectateur reconquis par chaque
nouvel épisode
la capacité qu'avait le service public
de bien exposer des programmes plus
exigeants grâce au report des
téléspectateurs en deuxième et troisième
partie de soirée n'existe plus au delà
de la souplesse légitime que requiert le
traitement par le 20 heures d'une
actualité dont la densité est par nature
variable la question même de la
pertinence d'un horaire réglementaire du
début de soirée doit être posée est
débattue c'est toute la culture
télévisuelle qui doit évoluer si nous
voulons continuer à animer l'audiovisuel
de création en france et ne pas nous
mettre hors jeu
ce chantier est une révolution
culturelle pour nous tous sa mise en
oeuvre
indispensable nécessite du temps afin de
faire évoluer notre écosystème et nos
missions traduite sous forme
d'engagements et de cahier des charges
je vous remercie pour votre attention et
bien entendu je suis prêt à présent avec
mes collaborateurs à répondre à vos
questions revenir sur les questions vous
avez évoqué oui ce propos préliminaires
global aurait pu en partie un certain
nombre de termes d'action mais
maintenant ce que je souhaiterais c'est
que ce soit un peu plus direct et qu'on
s'entraide
il ya une question que je n'ai pas posé
parce que dans mon propos préliminaires
parce que c'est il fait l'objet en
du loup a séparés mais qui a été
discutée quand même dans le cadre est
même souvent plus discutée que le rêve
dans le cadre de ce débat sur la réforme
de l'audiovisuel et c'est une question
très directe que je vous pose bien que
vous qui pouvez y répondre de cette
façon après chacun a son opinion mais
c'est là votre rat manque que je veux
avoir
vous savez que il ya eu la controverse
sur le mode de nomination des présidents
de l'audiovisuel public
vous vous souvenez que certains étaient
pour ce mode de nomination ici dans les
co rapporteurs monsieur legendre
moi j'étais pas favorable mais une fois
que c'était décidé j'avais déjà posé une
question au moment de on a dû à se
prononcer sur votre nom et vous saviez
que je n'avais absolument rien contre la
personne et ses compétences et ses
qualités mais je posais la question
est-ce que ça va être un boulet je
posais pas la question est ce que tous
les jours vous aurez président la
république au téléphone posé la question
sur est-ce que ce mode de nomination
indépendamment de ce qui se passe
ensuite dans la réalité ne faisait pas
de ne crée pas une situation même quand
une décision est prise de façon
indépendante
eh bien le doute la suspicion pouvait
jaillir se poser parce que c'était le
président la république qui nommer et
donc je vous demande
après avoir posé cette question au
moment de votre six nominations
après l'exercice si vous avez un des
moments penser
bien sûr vous avez toujours dû penser
que c'était bien ce que vous faites et
que c'était la tâche de votre vie et que
et que donc que vous êtes le plus
qualifié pour le faire ça c'est normal
mais est-ce que vous n'êtes pas penser
que vous auriez préféré être nommé
différemment pour pour encore être plus
heureux et et moins et moins regarder
parfois avec le doute je vous pose les
questions de façon directe ou me
connaissent et en même temps de façon
omnium agressive je pense que le temps
qui n'ont le temps qui nous est imparti
ne nous permettent pas faire une grande
dissertation sur le bonheur non ce que
je voudrais vous dire simplement c'est
que lorsque j'ai été nommé
j'ai présenté un projet ici même de même
je le fais au csa ou à l'assemblée et
que ce que je viens de vous exprimer là
est la traduction du projet que je veux
dont je vous parlais à l'époque assez
clairement
donc ma réponse est très simple c'est
que la mise en oeuvre de ce projet la
manière dont j'ai constitué mon équipe
dont les plus proches collaborateurs
sont présents et la manière dont nous
menons notre travail
dans l'entreprise est complètement
indépendante du mode de nomination
la seule question qui se pose concernant
le mode de nomination et là la rumeur
publique autour du mode de nomination
mais ce n'est pas l'exercice lui même de
la fonction ni l'exercice des
responsabilités qui est en jeu voilà
j'espère revenir sur le premier débat
celui qui concerne d'une certaine
manière l'audimat
nous sommes nous avons souhaité nous
avons pensé c'était peut-être naïf quand
la le mode de financement de la
télévision publique a été revue
c'est une façon de protéger
les chaînes contre ce qu'on appelait la
tyrannie de l'audimat
or quand j'écoute bien vos propos votre
préoccupation est de pouvoir attirer le
téléspectateur en début de soirée et si
possible de le garder vous avez expliqué
qu'il était très difficile de lui faire
passer d'une chaîne à une autre une fois
qu'ils étaient engagés dans une chaîne
dans le tunnel d'une chaîne est ce que
ça ne veut pas dire que finalement
l'audimat n'est pas liée au mode de
financement de que l'audimat ne persiste
pas même s'il n'est pas liée au mode de
financement de la télévision et que ce
qui est le critère sur lequel on juge le
succès ou l'échec d'une production et
d'un responsable de chaîne c'est sa
capacité à attirer le plus grand nombre
de téléspectateurs dans les
intervenantes l'avons rencontré lors de
ce travail on a beaucoup pour poser le
l'audimat et le kalimat est ce que vous
pourriez nous donner un petit peu votre
pensée sur ce sujet qui me paraît quand
même très important toujours dans un
souci de garder quand même à la
télévision l'aspect d'un élément de
notre culture
oui je je
je pas complète la question est très
complète mais j'ajoute de façon très
concrète ou partage pas tout mam eux
l'essentiel on ne partage pas mais ces
questions là où on les a partagées avec
monsieur le jean est et par exemple
quelqu'un nous a dit le réflexe reste à
9h12 le matin lendemain d'une projection
de notre création de notre homme de
notre production de nous appeler pour
nous donner l'audimat de la série ou du
film donc ça reste le critère vraiment
premier et on se sent on ne vous dit pas
voilà il ya tel audimat
mais tout le monde a adoré où on n'a pas
aimé ou non c'est l'audimat et le
chiffre de dix matches qui tombent pas
le calima on parle monsieur legendre et
donc on a l'impression que ça reste le
haut après vous m'avez vous donnez une
une explication à un moment donné qui
fait réfléchir aussi sur cette question
l'audimat sur le retard d'horaires 45 et
c'est notamment le fait que la riposte à
ce au début vous étiez bien à 35 au 1
la réponse de tf1 était de mettre contre
nous à ce moment là et donc si c'est un
succès populaire que si les
téléspectateurs étaient surtout pendant
un quart d'heure que vous commencez vos
émissions il ne pouvait plus revenir sur
votre prime time puisqu'il était
commencée et donc vous préférez reculé
aussi donc encore une fois l'impératif a
été et dans la concurrence et dans la
recherche de nîmes at par rapport à
quelque chose qui était très clairement
affichée comme une volonté du
législateur
parce que ça identifier la réforme il y
avait un arrêt de la pub il y avait 20
heures 35 stellaire avant tout le monde
est nettement avant tout le monde
une télévision qui permettait de voir
une deuxième partie de soirée avant de
se coucher pour ceux qui se lèvent tôt
c'étaient les télés les grandes vedettes
de 2007-2009 ceux qui se lèvent tôt donc
qu'est ce que vous dites par rapport à
cela alors les questions que vous posez
sont évidemment au coeur de deux de la
gestion des antennes première chose il
n'y a aucun doute là dessus
les missions que nous avons sont des
missions qui se différencie fortement
des chaînes privées à travers la
création à travers l'information et pour
cela il suffit de regarder nos grilles
de programmes de faire l'exercice
semaine après semaine et devoirs semaine
après semaine la place que nous donnons
aux documentaires de création aux
émissions culturelles à la fiction
française versu la fiction américaine ou
un magazine de société ou découvertes
il ne peut pas y avoir de doute
là-dessus et c'est jour après jour c'est
jour après jour vous avez ce soir sur
france 3 la nouvelle émission de patrick
de carolis le grand tour que je vous
conseille de voir qui vous faire
découvrir des choses formidables
vous êtes la fiction française sur
france 2 qu'est-ce que vous avez / / / /
france sur tf1
surfant sur tf1 ou sur m6 il n'y a pas
de doute là dessus et je pourrai vous le
faire semaine après semaine donc notre
première vocation est bien d'avoir jour
après jour et savez je ne fais pas là
dessus
de grands discours théorique jeu pardon
je regarde simplement le jour on me pose
cette question le programme du jour
et je ne suis jamais pris en défaut
est-ce que vous pensez que là dessus il
ya un avant et un après réforme est là
dessus parce qu'il n'y avait pas
france télévisions ne ressemblait pas à
tf1 avant la réforme mais mais l'a su il
ya un avant et après réforme parce
qu'aujourd'hui les risques que nous
prenons en termes de nouvelles fictions
les risques que nous prenons au terme de
documentaires en première partie de
soirée sont des risques comprenait plus
difficilement à l'époque puisque
l'audience commerciale prix mais pour
autant on en prenait quand même mais pas
de façon aussi systématique les
documentaires que vous voyez en première
partie de soirée
les fictions françaises l'évoquait tout
à l'heure les nouveaux magazines que
nous essayons de lancer sont
systématiquement aujourd'hui la marque
du service public il n'y a pas de
différence
il ya une différence marquée plus tôt
alors la question du des horaires
d'abord pardon mais le groupe france
télévisions ses cinq chaînes sur ses
cinq chaînes il se trouve que france 3
commence en moyenne à 20h38 que france
ça commence en moyenne à 20h37 que
franska france 4 commençons moyens à
20h38 que france ô commencent à 20h35
bon et il se trouve que france 2 a
commencé en moyenne à 20h41 l'an passé
et est cette année à 20h44 dans le même
temps les chaînes privées tf1 m6 mais
l'ensemble des chaînes de la tnt
commence globalement vers 21h alors
est-ce que et le débat sur l'audimat
épatant un débat de course à l'audimat
qu'une volonté pour l'audiovisuel public
de faire en sorte que les oeuvres soient
des offres qui soit vu par le plus grand
nombre
ne faisons pas la course à l'audimat
parce que si nous faisions la course à
l'audimat
nous mettrions trois soirées de séries
américaines comme font les autres et où
il empile 4 soit séries américaines
notre volonté simplement c'est que
lorsque nous mettons une fiction
française donc la création française
lorsque nous mettons un magazine
culturel français est bien de faire en
sorte que nous puissions donner
l'occasion au plus grand nombre de venir
il se trouve que depuis 2007
nos concitoyens ne disent pas à 20h35 je
me branche sur le service public met dix
amateurs 35 je vaque à différentes
occupations parce que le mode de vie
c'est que je ne vais chercher mon
programme de première partie de soirée
que pearl que vers 20h50 c'est ça la
réalité et vous ne pouvez pas
aujourd'hui réglementées
oui on avait tort on avait tort pour
deux raisons non mais on avait c'est pas
dans la loi d'ailleurs le 20h35 n'est
pas dans la loi non avec torque de coire
est avant tout c'est que si vous voulez
globalement je le dis ici
nous devons aujourd'hui lorsque nous
sommes dans un univers de concurrence
qui s'est totalement démultiplier depuis
et dans ce domaine de concurrence vous
ne pouvez pas dire un moment donné j'ai
une pratique à moins et puis tous les
autres qui explose de partout
eh ben ils vivent leur vie il faut
aujourd'hui essayer de réfléchir où sont
les flux et dans ces flux voir comment
on peut essayer de s'inscrire alors nous
ne disons pas qu'on va démarrer à 20h à
21h d'ailleurs ne le faisons pas en
revanche son propre nom france 2 on a
aujourd'hui l'opportunité sur france 2
d'avoir un journal d'information à 20h
qui est devenu et sa qualitativement
nous le dit un journal de référence qui
est un journal qui multiplie les pages
importantes qui aujourd'hui va jusque
vers 35 et nous démarrons la première
partie de soirée du coup cinq ou six
minutes plus tard la mission de service
public n'est pas gâchée par ces cinq ou
six minutes
et si elle nous permet d'amener à nous
un peu plus de gens qui vont voir une
fiction française
un magazine politique où un documentaire
je pense qu'on est dans notre rôle
alors sur le point que vous évoquiez
bien sûr qu'un moment donné
le fait de réunir un public important
est humain des critères d'appréciation
mais c'est un des critères
d'appréciation pourquoi parce que celle
usage de l'argent public si nous
utilisons la zone l'argent public pour
n'avoir que des audiences infime vous
nous offrez légitimement leurs proches
donc il ya un équilibre difficile à
trouver pour autant ce concernant le
qualitatif il faut que vous sachiez que
avons investi beaucoup sur les nouveaux
baromètre qualitatif mais que les
baromètre qualitatif ce sont des études
qualitatives à plus longue que l'audimat
instantanée et nous les avons que huit
jours plus tard mais avec notamment tous
ceux qui font de la fiction tous ceux
qui font des magazines récurrents nous
avons des réunions d' analyse
qualitative pour voir comment on peut à
partir de ces éléments qualitatifs tiré
de leçon pour progresser et être
meilleur mais le qualitatif est
aujourd'hui non seulement un point sur
lequel nous avons investi mais un point
sur lequel nous souhaitons aujourd'hui
dialoguer fortement avec les créateurs
essaient raison pour laquelle aussi nous
avons signé avec tous les professionnels
de la fiction il ya maintenant six mois
une charte du développement qui doit
nous permettre d'aller d'aller plus loin
mais encore une fois notre vrai enfin si
j'ai une vision de l'entreprise s'est
développée une information de référence
est une création qui est une création
originale
c'est ça notre notre rue oui monsieur le
jeu si j'ai bien compris ce que vient de
nous dire que le président de france
télévisions ne faut pas s'attacher trop
à l'heure à laquelle démarre là les
émissions sans publicité dans la
deuxième partie de la de la journée mais
vous et de ce point de vue le haut
penser qu une focalisation sur le
vainqueur 20h35 même s'il n'était pas
strictement dans la loi serait quelque
chose d'erroné et vous avez dit aussi
que la qualité s'est améliorée par
rapport à l'époque où france télévisions
pouvaient bénéficier de la publicité
donc il ne faut pas revenir un
financement par la publicité pour
l'avenir c'est bien ça votre pause
oui oui ce qu'on a pu entendre le débat
et si je savais je vous le confirme je
confirme c'est simplement parce que le
la prolongation de la publicité sous la
forme du parrainage pouvait apparaître
de ce point de vue là comme une
tentation ou l' amorce d'un retour au
financement par la publicité comme il ya
des tentations dans ce domaine je suis
heureux de l'entendre dire qu'il ne faut
pas revenir à un financement par la
publicité
quelles que soient les difficultés
financière de la période alors c'est le
gendre deux points là dessus le premier
c'est que je le dis ici je le redis je
considère que les missions du service
public sont tellement importantes et
aujourd'hui encore plus que par le passé
pour avoir une information de référence
est un lieu de création que nous devons
avoir le financement pour ses missions
mais qui sont des missions aujourd'hui
et j'en ai une conviction profonde plus
importante que jamais parce qu'il ya une
démultiplication de l'information et des
images et on doit avoir un lieu de
référence comme les autres grands
audiovisuel public européen donc il nous
faut un financement adapté et donc la
question de la publicité aujourd'hui se
pose pour moi très simplement dans l'
équilibre de ce financement
si l'esprit de la loi est respectée
c'est dire si on dit on vous supprime la
publicité et on compense
je crois que ça se disait à l'époque à
l'euro près il n'y a aucune difficulté
je constate ce n'est pas tout à fait le
cas actuellement la deuxième chose
concernant le parrainage à votre demande
et la demande de la commission de
l'assemblée nationale nous avons mis en
place une charte du parrainage nous
l'avons respecté
il faut que vous sachiez que le coût de
cette charte du parrainage c'est 10
millions d'euros de recettes en moins
pour nous c'est 10 millions n'ont pas
été compensés mais nous avons respecté
cette jarre du parrainage
alors qu'il reste des émissions que nous
parrainons ça fait partie aujourd'hui de
notre chiffre d'affaires qui est dans
notre contrat d'objectifs et de moyens
que l'on puisse avoir
on n'a plus de programme court après
20h30 on a juste des bandes-annonces
avec éventuellement du parrainage mais
aujourd'hui nous respectons ce cadre ce
cadre nous a encore une fois fait une
moins value en termes de recettes
publicitaires de l'ordre de 10 millions
pour le reste je le redis c'est la
question de l'évaluation de l'importance
de nos missions je les ai dans mon
propos introductif et du financement de
ces missions et si ses missions son
capital et elles sont capitales je crois
aujourd'hui pour la communauté nationale
il faut que nous trouvions financement
houdain et j'ai deux petites questions
oui sur le coût de la publicité et votre
souci des compensations par deux fois je
vous ai interrogé mais je n'étais pas
encore présidente de la commission sur
le coup
capus trait à vos recettes la
suppression de la publicité aux
alentours des émissions pour les enfants
ça pourrait arriver dans l'année et si
ça arrivait et que vous souhaitez
toujours que ce soit compensé il sera
vraiment nécessaire que vous nous
précise y est combien cela vous coûtera
alors je ne suis pas en mesure la mg et
collaborateurs non plus de vous donner
un chiffre est grave mais on fera
l'étudiant boulot et on vous le
transmettra évidemment nous a fait une
annonce un ca peut arriver sera plus
seulement milices de la culture
président de la commission je voulais
poser deux questions précises qui au qui
ont surgi à travers nos auditions qui
ont été notamment sur l'identité des
chaînes puisque vous avez insisté sur
sur sûr ça quand vous êtes arrivé
c'était la spécificité aussi de votre
mandat de votre équipe de votre projet
rapport à l'équipe précédente
tout le monde s'interroge réellement sur
france 4 sur le fait qu' on ne voit pas
on ne voit toujours pas l'identité
apparemment se dégager un consensus
d'une chaîne jeunesse manière qu'ils
pouvaient être sur une tranche horaire
plutôt les enfants et ensuite
progressivement gap d'aidés publiques
plus plu à dos et plus
jeune adulte au fur et à mesure de la
progression dans la soirée certains
s'émeuvent certains s'émeuvent du fait
que c'est l'endroit où quasiment
l'obligation de service public est
serait la moins la moins respectée en
termes de création française puisque il
ya beaucoup beaucoup quand même deux
feuilletons américains
on va dire et si c'est la méthode pour
garder les ados semblent pas être la
mission du service public tout cas je
vous le dis c'est des critiques
récurrentes qui nous sont venus dans les
auditions au mieux les connaître mais
les traités que deux peut-être qu'il ya
beaucoup d'injustices moi je ne suis pas
accroché à france 4 pour vérifier je le
fais quand je peux voir la télé parfois
mais je vous le dis c'est venu souvent
ne veut avoir votre point de vue il y
avait un objectif dans la loi sur des
obligations concernant la diversité que
la télé ressemble à la population
française dans ce qu'elle affiche dans
ce qu'elle montre dans ce qu'elle traite
et la population française et univers
donc je sais que beaucoup aient fait je
sais que vous avez un service quasiment
entièrement dédié tendue vers cet
objectif vous mais je veux avoir votre
votre réponse là dessus et puis il y a
bien sûr tout ce qui était tout ce qui
est lié
vous êtes un connaisseur mais le
chantier france 3 où on en est on est
avec pas où on en est comme ça de façon
générale mais où sont les problèmes
est ce que vous êtes satisfait est ce
que vous pensez que ça va pas assez vite
est-ce que vous pensez que
nous sommes en tous les cas nous au
sénat particulièrement attaché à la
l'identité fr3 chaîne des régions chaîne
des territoires et caetera et et
on aimerait vraiment qu'à aucun moment
des difficultés rencontrées par le
groupe
ce soit là qu'on laisse un peu tomber
les choses au cou parce que c'est la
spécificité peut-être majeur aussi du
service public de l'audiovisuel
concernant france 4 je l' ai évoqué dans
mon propos liminaire de deux choses
d'abord je crois qu'au fond on n'a pas
le temps malheureusement mais vraiment
nous sommes à votre disposition lorsque
vous le souhaiterez pour détailler avec
vous le contenu de france 4 ce que nous
faisons en termes de magazines ce que
nous faisons en termes de création ce
que nous faisons en termes de
d'initiative si tu es tout à l'heure un
papier d'une journaliste où on a fait
dans la peau d'un handicapé des débats
des magazines documentaires formidable
bref nous avons dans cette chaîne une
différenciation complète avec l'univers
de la tnt
cette chaîne elle fait partie du bouquet
de france télévisions nous sommes dans
un univers aujourd'hui on est passé de
la rareté à la profusion et dans cette
profusion
il faut que vous sachiez que le fait
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait six chaînes de
plus fait que la part de voix de france
télévisions est passé de 28 % à 20 %
notre part de voix diminue et elle
diminue alors que nous avons des
missions importantes et alors que nous
devons essayer de toucher tout le monde
est touché tout le monde sait en
particulier toucher les jeunes adultes
qui ont des pratiques culturelles
totalement différente et ces jeunes
adultes aujourd'hui
eh bien il se trouve qu'ils regardent
france 4 de plus en plus puisque france
qu'as tu es la chaîne qui chez les
jeunes adultes à la progression
d'audience la plus forte depuis un an et
france 4 c'est ni plus ni moins le même
type de chaîne que je l'évoqué dans mon
propos que celle qu'ont qu'on lançait
les allemands les anglais les italiens
récemment pourquoi parce que le service
public aujourd'hui mais dans l'ensemble
des pays européens touche
majoritairement les plus de 50 ans les
plus de 55 ans population importante
population qui d'ailleurs va continuer
à à s'agrandir puisque on sait que la
population vieillit donc population que
nous ne laisserons pas tomber mais si
nous ne nous adressons pas avec des
canaux spécifiques aux jeunes adultes
qui aujourd'hui encore une fois des
pratiques culturelles qui sont en train
de changer
alors ça veut dire que nous considérons
que le service public n'a pas à
s'adresser à ces jeunes adultes et que
la marque france télévisions est une
marque qui est réservé aux plus âgés
c'est pas possible
donc c'est un enjeu stratégique à cet
enjeu stratégique positif mais sur quel
type d'émission mais si on peut vous le
montrer sur le sur l'ensemble de la
grille et pas seulement sur les délais
les séries américaines comme vous
l'évoquez tout à l'heure on a du cinéma
on a des magazines on a des magazines
qui fonctionne extrêmement bien mais ça
encore une fois je vous proposerai cible
des maths en progression bien sûr
évidemment oui et ça on peut vous le
montrer très très très clairement dans
notre commission ne pense que les qu'il
n'y a pas de raison d'avoir une chaîne
pour les jeunes nous sommes tous bien
convaincu la question c'est plutôt celle
de la construction de l'identité delà de
cette chaîne qui paraît encore un petit
peu grise à l'horizon c'est sûrement pas
de ne pas vouloir du mal à chaîne et
déjà donc bien au contrat donc il faut
qu'on travaille donc il faut une légende
il faut qu'on travaille là dessus pour
progresser pour la faire mieux connaître
pour partager cela avec vous et avec nos
concitoyens
vous évoquez le la chaîne enfants je
vous le redis ici je pense que le
service public doit avoir une chaîne
enfants et doit avoir une chaîne enfant
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
il se trouve que si nous n'avons pas une
chaîne enfants avec de la création
française et européenne
les seules chaînes que nos enfants
regardent ce sont des chaînes
américaines ou asiatiques
la deuxième le deuxième point c'est
qu'il se trouve que nous sommes le
premier financeur de l'animation en
france qui est la première animation en
europe et que nous avons donc des droits
que nous pouvons utiliser sur cette
chaîne enfants alors nous n'avons pas eu
d'attribution alors qu'on aurait pu
avoir une attribution sur une chaîne
enfants nous ne l'avons pas eue
mais il faut qu'on travaille le sujet et
et
ce que nous pensons c'est que dans notre
groupe il y a la place pour une chaîne
jeune adulte et une chaîne pour les
enfants mais vous avez mille fois raison
différente
pourquoi c'est des questions aujourd'hui
dans la profusion dans laquelle nous
sommes d'installation de marque
eh bien on fait de deux manières soit on
arrive à transformer un canal qui existe
actuellement et qui serait disponible
demain ou après demain il va y avoir des
mouvements sur la tnt ou alors nous
pouvons trouver des désaccords avec
gulli dans lequel nous sommes
minoritaires mais en tout cas un
chantier à ouvrir les évoquer pardon la
question de dieu sur la publicité
j'ai pas de chiffres sur les le chiffre
d'affaires publicitaire autour des cases
jeunesse alors cela dépend du ce qu'on
remonte au tour au milieu ou après les
cases jeunesse sur l'ensemble de nos
chaînes sachant que france 5 n'a pas de
publicité autour des cases jeunesse
on a une manière une bonne vingtaine de
millions d'euros
et c'est en baisse au cours des derniers
mois parce que l'audience de ces cases
s'effrite au profit de au profit de
chaînes thématiques
alors ce point click évoque sans réagir
allant jusqu'à supprimer le budget de
l'état cette année
oui dans le cas des économies ce
qu'évoque martin ajdari est aussi
extrêmement important c'est que vous
savez que nous avons aujourd'hui des
cases jeunesse sur france 2 sur france 3
sur france 5 sur france 4 et ses 15
jeunesse attendant et france ô et ses
cases jeunesse ont des audiences qui
baissent fortement
pourquoi parce que les enfants
aujourd'hui vont bien davantage sur des
chaînes qui leur sont dédiés que sur les
chaînes généralistes où ils trouvent des
15 jeunesse c'est ainsi je signale aussi
et c'est par rapport au numérique nous
allons lancer une application ouzou que
bruno patino m'a présenté il ya quelques
jours et qui sera opérationnel qu'en
bruno dans les jours qui viennent et
donc vous aurez sur ipad une application
zouzou pour les tout-petits où vous
pourrez voir des dessins animés pour les
tout petits
vous pourrez voir des jeux pour les
tout-petits etc etc et qui est donc une
façon pour nous aussi d'occuper ce
terrain avec des
application bruno tu peux exclure les
iphone ce qu'il faut pas que les
tout-petits et ça mais en fait ça va
être une application pour les tablettes
on sait qu'aujourd'hui les tablettes
sont en fait des outils partagé qui
reste souvent quand chez les détenteurs
de tablettes sur la table du salon
donc en fait on crée avec cette
application aux ou à la fois la capacité
de choisir donc les zozos c'est une
marque de france 5-1 donc ludo
éducatives pour les tout petits mais
vraiment les sur un sur un thème
ludo-éducatif j'insiste et on pourra
avoir soit j'allais dire une télévision
linéaire ludo-éducative toute la journée
ou choisir ses dessins animés et je sais
ce que vous allez me demander donc je
vais vous répondre en tout cas je
l'imaginé sans doute je me trompe il ya
un minuteur possible c'est à dire que
les parents qui ont un code d'accès
peuvent minutes et le nombre enfin le
temps qui peut être visionnée par leurs
enfants donc il ne reste pas forcément
toute la journée devant la tablette
bon ça c'est tout là je vais pas vous
faire le procès mais il ya quand même
une grande perversité dans ce qui est en
train de se passer globalement je suis
parent on offre la chose et ensuite on
veut la limite et ont dû regarder nous
sommes éthique nous limitons je veux
dire oui moi je laisse ma tablette sur
la table déjà mon fils sans part des
choses mais je vois qui rend dans des
applications pas possible il va aller
chercher etc
je suis pas content je suis pas allé me
dire comment je vais lui faciliter pour
qui les sont programmées tous à table je
veux juste qui la touchent pas parce que
c'est pas son truc
bon m'enfin bon vous avez le droit de
c'est normal que comme il ya vous savez
que il ya ce type de consommation que le
service public aussi fasse une offre
puisque les autres enfants kung fu et
comme l'offre sera certainement de
meilleures qualités je je
dire bravo mais mais voilà c'est ça tous
les cas ça montre que vous êtes
innovants et que et que dans tous les
domaines vous voulez être dans une
compétition est gelée soulignait tout à
l'heure ça vous est reconnu complètement
parrot par beaucoup d'acteurs alors vous
est posée au président une question sur
france 3 je l'évoquais dans mon propos
liminaire france 3 est évidemment un
chantier principal pour moi et les
principales pour moi d'abord parce que
s'il y a dans la notion de service
public c'est à dire égalité d'accès pour
tous aux mêmes services au même type de
contenu quel que soit mon lieu
d'habitation alors france 3 où ce rôle
là et joue ce rôle là de façon parfaite
dans un univers où aujourd'hui on l'a
observé l'offre privée ne parvient pas à
se développer
alors nous avons au cours des derniers
mois d'abord développer les contenus
régionaux notamment termes de politique
documentaire magazine conforter les les
pages d'information et les pages
spéciales maintenant nous travaillons
sur un projet qui est un projet qui doit
nous conduire à avoir demain autour
d'offres régional que nous structurons
et ben développement de l'offre une
spécificité dans chaque région et je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure dans mon
propos
quelque chose qui pourraient toutes
choses égales par ailleurs concernant
les que les contraintes budgétaires
aller vers ce qu'a fait la rdc à dire
des grandes plaques de chaînes
régionales de télévision publique
bien merci monsieur oui alors assez vite
enfin une question qui ne qui
n'existerait pas de trop longs
développements parce que je voudrais que
vente on pense vraiment à l'heure dans
ce que nous venons de voir j'ai
l'impression que
on considère comme un fait acquis que le
téléspectateur un jour donné sans
fournis dans un tunnel
une chaîne et qu'il n'en sortira plus
guère jusqu'à la fin de la soirée
est ce que le service public est ce que
france télévisions essaye de présenter
l'ensemble des programmes qui sont sur
ces chaînes parce qu'un téléviseur un
thé un téléspectateur mature c'est
peut-être celui qui est capable de faire
son choix
il n'y a pas que des bonnes émission sur
une chaîne la même soirée il peut être
intéressant d'apprendre ou d'être
incités à sauter d'une chaîne sur
l'autre en fonction de ses goûts
comment allez vous faire pour présenter
l'offre globale de votre chaîne à vos
téléspectateurs et sortir cas c'est un
peu ce tunnel alors vous avez mille fois
raison il faut que nous puissions
développer ce qu'on appelle la promotion
croisée
donc nous allons essayer de mettre en
place un travail que nous faisons entre
les chaînes d'abord de mettre en valeur
pour chaque chaîne le programme
important de la journée ou de la semaine
de faire en sorte que sur les autres
chaînes on puisse présenter ce programme
là de faire aussi en sorte que nous
ayons des bandes-annonces croisé à ce
que nous sommes en train de faire et
puis autre point sur lequel nous
travaillons c'est la possibilité de
faire circuler les oeuvres c'est dire si
une oeuvre est particulièrement
marquante sur une chaîne de pouvoir le
présenter sur d'autres chaînes aussi
bref de faire en sorte qu'on donne envie
et qu'on fasse en sorte que le maximum
de gens puissent découvrir ce que nous
faisons merci monsieur le président je
pense que votre cette édition était tout
à fait importante éclairant elle a
permis de répondre à beaucoup de nos
interrogations jeu
pour moi la principale nouveauté que je
ne juge pas c'est que vous ayez dit
parce que c'est important
si c'est ça de l'assumer y compris de
réfléchir si les choses doivent évoluer
dans dans le rapport entre la puissance
publique et france télévisions vous avez
dit que l'idée de 20h35 n'était pas une
bonne idée
dans tous les cas handicapés france
télévisions le problème c'est que vous
pouvez convaincre mais le décret c'est
la loi même si c'est pas dans la loi et
que donc vous ne pouvez pas sans que les
pouvoirs publics mouge là dessus
continuez à transgresser
mais nous tracions de la loi nous ne
transgressons pas nous sommes à oz le
décret le décret n'est aux alentours de
20 heures 35 nous avons cinq chaînes et
si je fais la moyenne des cinq chaînes
nous sommes moins de 20h40 c'est à dire
aux alentours de 20 heures 35 bien mais
où ai dit oui moi aussi j'ai fait un
petit constat qui me paraît intéressant
au cours de cette audition
malgré les abominables conditions dans
lesquelles le président de france
télévisions est nommé c'est un homme
heureux et c'est un président libre
alors je je je je veux finir en vous
disant bon c'est la principale
et puis je veux faire vérifier parce que
c'est une nouveauté pour moi
peut-être que je suis si peu si peu
avertis que mais en tous les cas c'est
une nouveauté
vous affirmez que aujourd'hui le
comportement du téléspectateur c'est de
rentrer sur une chaîne et d'en sortir le
plus tard possible en école et que donc
non mais je vous lis parce que quand
même jusqu'à présent on était sur le
téléspectateur a peur puisque l'offre
s'était élargie et le téléspectateur
passait d'un truc à l'autre etc
vous êtes en train de dire que il
res et donc il faut le garder parce que
c'est ça la garantie pour que il se
fidélise et c'est donc on reviendra il
comprit comme je veux que nous
regardions nous mêmes de plus près si
c'est bien ça le comportement du
téléspectateur je vous interrogera pour
que vous êtes payé cette affirmation et
on intégrera ou rapport votre point de
vue je veux vous direz vous annoncer que
contrairement à ce qui était prévu je le
dis pour les membres de la commission
notamment
nous devions dans notre programme pour
rendre le rapport le rendre la semaine
prochaine
j'ai demandé
mon co rapporteurs s'il était d'accord
puisque j'ai proposé de le rendre ce
rapport autour du 15 mai pour qu' il ne
soit pas un élément disons à la veille
d'élections et pendant cette période
électorale qui puisse créer de la
polémique parce que même quand il n'y a
pas matière à polémique
très souvent dans ces moments là on la
crée sa atteint aux travaux à la
crédibilité ou à l'autorité de nos
travaux donc je préfère que ce que l'on
va faire soit absolument une
contribution majeure à ce débat et qu'il
soit considéré comme tel comme souvent
les travaux du sénat
je veux pas qu'ils sont tachées de quoi
que ce soit donc monsieur legendre a m'a
dit qu'il était ravi que je fasse cette
proposition eh bien nous sommes ravis
ensemble unis et à bientôt
ce poison laissez moi sur ce point
explique moi même mes sentiments pour
dire simplement que votre death note
décision collective me paraît sur ce
point sage bien
excusez moi je n'avais pas vu c'est
probablement ou l'a mal transmis mais
madame en 1/2 c voulait dire quelque
chose je suis à mon avis un petit moment
monsieur le président je vais être du
coup est très brève puisque le temps
imparti à la possibilité aux collègues
de poser des questions finalement est
plus que limité alors que nous
atteignons je voulais juste posé deux
trois questions qui sont faites sont
dans le droit fil du rapport d'étape que
nous avions conduit avec claude bellot
qui est tout à fait dans l'esprit du
suivi de l'application de la loi dans
notre rapport à l'époque monsieur bello
monsieur primes là nous soulignons
l'importance
la mise en oeuvre de l'entreprise unique
nous avions bien lié à l'époque c'était
un chantier compliqué et difficile et
que ça pouvait pas se faire comme vous
l'avez souligné en un jour mais on avait
souligné l'importance qu'elle se
conjugue à une amélioration de la
gouvernance en matière notamment
d'orientation stratégique au sein du
conseil d'administration est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire en quelques mots en
quoi celle ci a pu être améliorée depuis
les deux dernières années nous avions
pointé deux choses la question de
l'identité des chaînes dont avait parlé
le retard du média global des mesures
ont été prises nous l'avons constaté
depuis sur ce dernier point monsieur
patino est intervenue j'aurais aimé
avoir un complément d'information
notamment ce qui concerne la télévision
de rattrapage les services en ligne
l'offre de films j'ai cru comprendre que
les négociations avaient lieu avec des
producteurs et que les accords étaient
presque atteint et il y aurait rupture
des négociations au jour d'aujourd'hui
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un petit
peu plus c'est un petit peu aussi
quelques mots sur la formation nécessité
par l'instauration du média global ou
est-ce que vous en êtes aussi parce que
c'est un point que nous avions à
l'époque souligné desailly vraiment il
ya un malentendu et aucun de mes ce qui
m'aide à travailler
on avait vu votre me levais donc moi je
ne peux pas là je sais vraiment j'aurais
même et monsieur trévidic et à la porte
a très peu de temps pour son audition je
peux pas lui dire qu'on va rien cocon
que tant de retard donc ce que je
pensais vocations sont absolument
essentielles importante coulée voulait
transmettre
si vous pouvez si vous pouvez nous faire
des réponses assez précise et que vous
répondiez la oralement au moins
globalement mais pourront répondre plus
précisément à l'ensemble des questions
il ya plus le temps de trois points sur
la gouvernance nous avons un comité
stratégique au sein du conseil
d'administration qui maintenant est
consulté c'est dire que la gouvernance a
été voulu et que des comités et ses
comités travaillent à l comité des
engagements comité stratégique et ses
comités donne des avis qui éclaire le
conseil
donc lorsqu'on a des gros dossiers qu'on
arrive au conseil les comités auront
travaillé auprès au préalable
la deuxième chose concernant la
télévision de rattrapage
nous avons aujourd'hui télévision de
rattrapage qui meuble qui fonctionne sur
l'ensemble de notre offre pas sur le
cinéma parce que sur le cinéma
aujourd'hui à une discussion liée à la
monétisation des films
deux ans après ou trois ans après et
donc des discussions que les producteurs
un peu compliqué mais la télévision de
rattrapage s'est passé globalement il ya
un peu plus d'un an à 2 millions de
vidéos vues par mois et nous sommes
aujourd'hui à 40 millions de vidéos vues
donc la télévision trappage marche et
elle va continuer à se développer
nous avons parallèlement développer
l'offre de vod et l'offre de vod qui va
être mise en ligne maintenant de façon
très sur les différentes plateformes
dans les quinze jours trois semaines qui
viennent
puis qu'il va monter en puissance -
enfin on démarre
en mai donc dans les trois semaines de
guerre oui c'est cette v à des
fonctionne pour le cinéma pour la
formation
nous avons une formation importante sur
le nom propre vous en veut envoyer le
plan de formation que patrice papet
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
voilà pour l'audition de rémy pflimlin
pdg de france télévisions pour la revoir
notre site internet
public sénat